China will soon hold the Olympic Games in Beijing...
...and they will start at the luckiest possible moment.
According to tradition,...
...8 is an auspicious number in China...
...and therefore the Olympics will start on August 8, 2008 at 8 p.m.
Eight is considered very lucky in China...
...because its pronunciation sounds the same as the word for...
..."to make money" in Cantonese.
Chinese culture is steeped in superstition,...
...with numbers playing a major role in birthdays, wedding dates and naming.
Six, eight and nine are considered lucky numbers,...
...while four, seven and even one are considered more unfortunate.
The pronunciation of nine means everlasting,...
...particularly in relationships,...
...while six means things will go smoothly.
Telephone numbers, license plates and even residential or business addresses...
...that use any of them or any combination of those numbers...
...are extremely popular.
Conversely,...
...anything involving the numbers four and seven are avoided as much as possible.
Four sounds like the Chinese word for death.
Seven translates as "gone" which can also mean death,...
...while one can signify loneliness.